SEEMA VASHI: Thank
you for coming.
My name is Seema, and
I am really, really
excited to be hosting
this panel today.
All of you know why you're here.
But the lovely Lauren
Epshteyn has recently--
[CHEERING]
[APPLAUSE]
--recently published
her first novel--
historical fiction-- called
"A Northern Gentleman."
For the first 25, we have books
out there you guys can grab.
But we just wanted to take
some time in this hour
to get to know more about
her experience writing
this book, her inspiration.
We're actually going
to also have some time
to have her read a chapter and
have a little mini book club
conversation, as
I like to call it.
There will be time at the end
to ask your own questions,
so think about them.
But let's go ahead
and bring Lauren up.
Thank you.
This is exciting.
LAUREN EPSHTEYN:
Thank you, Seema.
Thank you for interviewing
me today and hosting.
I asked Seema to
interview me in front
of so many of my
close Google friends
because she is fantastic
at doing exactly that.
She's hosted many
panels at Google before,
so thank you for your time
today, and thank all of you
for coming.
It means the world to me that
you would come, and some of you
are participating today.
I know just about all of
you, but thank you so much
for your time.
SEEMA VASHI: So
let's kick it off.
We all know why we're
here for this book,
and you wrote this book.
Can you talk a little
bit about what prompted
you to even go on this journey?
LAUREN EPSHTEYN: So I've
always loved writing.
I'm a big believer
in if you want
to figure out what
you're passionate about
or realize what you're
passionate about, look back
to what you had
fun doing as a kid.
And for me, writing stories was
absolutely one of those things
that I loved doing as a kid.
I remember when I
was 10 years old,
we had a family reunion that
had a questionnaire that said,
what's your life goal?
Or what do you hope
you do someday?
And at 10 years old I said, I
want to be a "New York Times"
best-selling author.
I don't even know how I knew
what that was at 10 years old,
but that's what I wanted to do.
So I'm not sure that
"A Northern Gentleman"
is going to achieve
that goal for me,
but when the story
came to me, I had
to at least give it a try-- try
writing fiction as an adult.
SEEMA VASHI: And so
going about this,
how did you know
how to write a book?
LAUREN EPSHTEYN: Good question.
So they say that readers
make the best writers.
Although, I was thinking
about it this morning-- no,
they say drinkers
make the best writers.
But they say readers
make the best writers,
and I have always been a
voracious reader, maybe not
as much as-- I know there's
actually a lot of Googlers who
read much more than I do,
and I'm inspired by you all.
But hopefully, then, you
can relate to this idea.
I personally have always loved
American historical fiction
perhaps the most.
Some of my favorite
books are by Gore Vidal,
or there's one in
particular that I loved
by an author named Jack Finney.
Does anybody know
"Time and Again"?
It's a great book,
where a guy who's
living in New York in the
year 1970 time travels back,
so there's a little
tiny bit of sci-fi
there, to New York in 1882.
And as I was researching
for America in the 1890s,
it was definitely
influential in understanding
what types of words that people
used, what types of activities
did people do in the 1800s and
late 1800s, so I love that.
I read a lot.
I also read a book
on how to write.
I read several.
One in particular, if anyone is
interested in writing a fiction
book, was by a literary
agent and editor named
Sol Stein called
"On Writing," and I
found that one really helpful.
The biggest takeaway
I had from that book
was that you need
to raise the stakes.
People will only be
interested in what you're
writing if they feel like
there's something big at stake,
whether it's someone's
life, or his classic example
is make it the
fate of the earth.
Is there an asteroid coming?
That wasn't as applicable
in a story like "A Northern
Gentleman," but I tried, when
possible, to raise the stakes.
And then my favorite
book on writing
is actually one
by a screenwriter.
Has anyone heard of the
book called "Save the Cat?"
Yeah, someone has.
Have you read it?
OK, so yeah, "Save
the Cat" is a book
on screenwriting, where
the "namesake rule," one
of his first rules of
writing, is that you have
to make the character likeable.
So early on, have
the main character
do something small
but very likable,
like saving a cat that's
stuck up in a tree.
So I tried after
reading that to make
Drucker, my main character,
do small little things,
whether it was
standing up for himself
or saying something clever back
to someone, that would make you
like him and root for him.
Rather than, actually, the very
initial version of Drucker, he
was a little pathetic.
He hated his job, which he does.
And if you read the
book, you'll know he
hates his job in the beginning.
But he was sort of
beaten down by it.
And then reading "Save the Cat"
really made him more empowered.
And then, finally,
if anyone else really
wants to write a book, the
thing I did when I started was I
took a class.
It was a four-month class at
Media Bistro, a couple hundred
bucks, and you stay accountable
for bringing your homework
every week.
And I did that for about
four months, and the takeaway
I had from that class--
it was fun to just
have others read your writing.
They gave me some good ideas.
They reminded me
that when you're
writing historical
fiction in particular,
the author knows things
that have actually
happened that the
characters don't, and so I
had a lot of fun with that.
There's one point, and I
won't give too much away,
where Drucker, the
main character,
suggests the idea of
something like a credit card.
And the people around
him think he's nuts.
You know, what?
That sounds horrible.
That will never work.
Because if you think
about it, in the 1890s,
that probably would have
sounded like a really bad idea
to someone who just had
a local credit account
with the local merchant.
So I had a lot of fun
with that, and that class
was really useful in that way.
SEEMA VASHI: Awesome.
So I think a lot of people
here, as well as myself, love
the idea of writing a book.
And you have a full time job.
When did you find the time?
When did you actually
get this done?
How long did it take?
LAUREN EPSHTEYN: I get
that question all the time.
And I wish that I had
a really clean answer,
like Tuesdays and Thursdays
from 6:00 to 9:00.
Like for some of my NYU
friends, you could just
have an easy answer for that.
It wasn't like that at all.
For me, it was sporadic.
And I say this
because if you have
a passion or a story
or an art project
or whatever it is that you think
you don't have the time for,
I hope that me sitting
up here is proof
that you don't need a
whole lot of free time
in order to make some
forward progress.
Sometimes I would challenge
myself to do 100 words a day,
usually in May, because that
rhymed-- 100 words a day
in May.
And then in June, I
wouldn't touch it.
And some days 500 words
would flow easily,
and other days getting to 99
would be a real challenge.
And then, like I said,
I wouldn't touch it
for the next month.
And actually, I put the
book down for four years.
I didn't touch it for
four years after writing
for an initial nine months.
And when I picked it
back up, the story
just came right back to me.
It was there waiting for me.
So that's why I knew I
had to keep going with it.
Why I say, again, to all
of you in the audience
and you watching, you don't
need a whole lot of free time
just to make some progress
on a story or a project that
means something to you.
SEEMA VASHI: So what
was that timeline, then?
So you said you worked
on it for nine months.
LAUREN EPSHTEYN: Yep,
so, yep, I started it.
I had moved to New
York summer 2007.
One year later, I got this
idea while sitting on a train
back from DC.
For any of you haven't read
the book yet, a lot of it
takes place on a train.
Train travel's a big
part of the book.
The idea came to
me first, actually;
I was playing
around with titles,
and I thought of "a
northern gentleman."
That just sounded
interesting to me.
And I thought, what
would that be about?
Well, definitely a
guy from the South,
and that's where I started.
And then I signed up for this
Media Bistro writing class,
took that for four months,
wrote for about the next five
after that, but then really put
it down and didn't touch it,
didn't have the time, had
a lot of other distractions
in my life for the
next four years.
And then when I graduated
from business school
in the spring of 2013 was
when I really picked it up.
And, you know, I can't say that
I had the Tuesday and Thursday
nights, three hours
at a time, but that's
when I really started
making the time,
even though it was sporadic.
SEEMA VASHI: And was this like
an internal goal for yourself,
or did you have
other people kind
of keeping you accountable?
I guess the class helped.
LAUREN EPSHTEYN: The class
helped, but that was only
in the beginning.
It was for me.
I had this story, and
I wanted to tell it.
And every time I came back to
it, it was still there for me,
and it was exciting and fun.
So it was really just for me
and holding it in my hand,
and having control
over the story
and the process was a
really good experience.
SEEMA VASHI: That's great.
So everyone here knows
that Lauren's name
is Lauren, not Lane.
So on the cover of the book you
see that she uses a pen name.
It's Lane Everett.
So could you explain why you
did that-- same initials?
LAUREN EPSHTEYN: Yes,
this is the question
I get the second most
after, how did you ever
find the time to do that?
Yes, I used a pen name.
I always wanted
to use a pen name.
It sounds a little bit
shallow or on the surface,
but I wanted something
unisex and All-American
on the cover of this book.
To me, this was like
an American story,
and I wanted something that
could have been written
by any classic American name.
So I wanted that.
But also-- and I
hope you guys can all
relate to this,
many of you being
in sales and engineering-- but
I am in client meetings a lot.
I didn't know who was going
to be saying something
about this book or another
book that I write in the future
and what they would be saying,
and I didn't want a client
googling "who just gave
me that advice on what
to do with my mobile strategy"
and finding something untoward
that someone would have
written about Drucker
or any other of my characters.
So I wanted to keep
that nice and separate,
really draw a line there.
And I know that sounds
clean in principle.
But I have to tell you, and
I think this is interesting,
I've been, in the
last couple months,
talking to everyone I can
find with some connection
to the book marketing industry.
And to a T, just about every
single one of them has said,
no, you need to republish
using your own name.
Why?
Because I know there are
many authors who historically
have used pen names.
There's some famous ones.
One of my favorite is
Ayn Rand, or Ayn Rand.
Her name was Alisa
Rosenbaum or something.
So many historical
authors did that.
But these days,
apparently, and so I hear,
it's not books that sell books.
It's authors that sell books.
And in this world
of social media,
it's really hard to
fake an identity.
And as I'm saying
these words, I'm
laughing to myself because I'm
like that's what Drucker did.
That's why it's so fun to
live vicariously through him
because he lived in this time
when you could fake an identity
and just start over again.
SEEMA VASHI: That's so cool.
LAUREN EPSHTEYN:
Yeah, so we'll see.
Right now, I'm keeping Lane
Everett, and I'm happy with it.
And, in fact, we're
launching-- we're launching?
I'm launching the book
to the public November 15
with Lane Everett.
If you pick up this
book now, you'll
see on the page it
says LE Everett inside.
That makes it a
classic first edition
copy, because as
of November 15th,
it'll actually say Lane Everett.
I decided to go full
forward movement
with Lane Everett for now.
SEEMA VASHI: And how did you
come up with Lane Everett?
LAUREN EPSHTEYN: I wish
I had a good story.
That one, there
truly is no story.
I just like it, and it has
LE like Lauren Epshteyn.
SEEMA VASHI: Did you want Lane
to be like could be a man,
could be a woman?
LAUREN EPSHTEYN: Yes, I
wanted something unisex.
And, again, to a T, the couple
of people who have said,
that is not unisex--
each one of them
has a different version of what
Lane absolutely is to them.
Some people said,
Lane's not unisex.
That's just a man's name.
Others have said, Lane-- I
know only know women Lanes.
So I think that
makes it very unisex.
SEEMA VASHI: Yes.
And what does it mean to
be launching to the public?
LAUREN EPSHTEYN: Aha!
So you all received
notice of this book
while it was in the friends
and family marketing phase.
And actually, the
beauty of that was
that I caught a
few things I wanted
to change-- not plot
wise, not structurally,
just a couple of formatting
things that I wanted to change.
And so, took it down
for three weeks.
I'm launching to the public
November 15th with some AdWords
campaigns and some PR and
some more in-person events.
SEEMA VASHI: Awesome,
that's great.
Cool, so now I think
now would be-- I mean,
people here know a little
bit of the background
of why you wrote the book.
Why don't we hear from the book?
You want to read
a chapter from it?
LAUREN EPSHTEYN: Yes, I
would love to do that.
So I'm going to read
you all Chapter 3,
because in this
chapter you're really
introduced to the main
character, Drucker
May, and some of the
struggles that he's
going through with
his father, who
is the president of
the bank and wants
Drucker to be president of the
bank, which Drucker doesn't
want.
Drucker's struggling
with his boredom at work.
And this is the point where he
really comes to the realization
that if you're unhappy
with something,
it's not that hard to
just get up and leave,
or to at least leave your
desk for a few minutes.
And people always ask me, how
autobiographical is this book?
And my answer is generally
that the autobiography
was very subtle.
There was little tiny moments.
He's going to get up from
his desk in this chapter.
And that was inspired
by back in 2008,
back when I was questioning,
I was a year out of college
and wondering, oh,
my god, am I going
to sit at a desk for the rest
of my life, all day every day?
I would just take one lap
around 76th and 9th Avenue,
and that made a lot of
difference in the afternoon,
just getting that
breath of fresh air.
And so I tried to
instill little pieces
of those actions in Drucker.
Anyway, so Chapter 3,
which I'm about to read,
I think it really introduces
what "A Northern Gentleman" is
really all about.
Yes, it's historical
fiction, but it's
about figuring out what you
want to do with your life
and finding the
courage to do so.
So let's go ahead.
SEEMA VASHI: I need to
get the Kindle version.
LAUREN EPSHTEYN: I have
the Kindle version.
Anyone already read
the Kindle version--
part of what was going
on with the re-release
is that Kindle formatted
it a little wrong.
So you'll have noticed a
couple of strange typos
that Amazon inserted.
But, no big deal; you should
have still gotten the idea.
Chapter 3-- "Halfway
through the week
that he been given to think of
a way to save Atlanta Southern
National Bank from a
swift and ugly collapse,
Drucker found
himself with nothing
to show for his efforts but
a page full of scribbles
and a pounding headache.
In those moments when
he wasn't battling
the throbbing in his
temples, he did his best
not to yield to Hank's
menacing voice in his head.
"Frankly, I don't even see
why you bother pretending.
That board meeting
makes no difference.
Your father will convince them
to vote you in no matter what."
Every time Drucker
felt himself getting
close to coming up with some
sort of plan for the bank,
those words would begin to ring
in his ears, distracting him.
He heard them again as he
stood next to his desk,
gazing out at the
sunny summer afternoon
on the other side of the
window, feeling guilty
that his efforts thus
far had been fruitless,
but also wondering
if perhaps there
wasn't a part of him
that wanted to fail
at this task he had been given.
After all, if he were to be
struck by a miraculous idea,
he could save face in
front of the board.
But then what?
A good showing in that
meeting would only
add fuel to the fire of his
father's already heated desire
to install Drucker in his post.
On the other hand,
if Drucker were
to show up at the board meeting
empty handed and unprepared,
he would certainly embarrass
both himself and his father.
But might a mediocre performance
in front of the board actually
be to his advantage?
It would certainly
tarnish his image,
perhaps in just the right way.
A disappointing show
at the board meeting
could heap a little extra
dirt on his already soiled
reputation, and it could be
just enough to prevent the board
from endorsing the president's
proposal of Drucker
as his successor.
The thought intrigued him, but
Drucker couldn't bring himself
to give up entirely just yet.
The family name was among
a small and dwindling list
of things that he and
his father shared.
To sully his own name would
be to drag his father's down
in the dirt, too, and he
couldn't bring himself
to do that to his father.
He couldn't deny
that a part of him
very much wanted to, though,
and the guilt of knowing it
gave Drucker a suffocating
itch in his lungs.
He felt the desperate
need for fresh air,
and so, very quietly, to avoid
catching anyone's attention,
he snuck out of the building.
The July day was warm
and drier than usual,
with a light breeze
that smelled alive
compared to the musty
air inside the bank.
Drucker walked to
the base of the tree
that he had so often gazed
at through the window.
He reached out and
touched the bark
and was surprised to find that
it was rough, that it was real.
In his mind, the tree
had become a symbol
of all that was outside
the bank and therefore
off limits to him.
He'd spent hours,
days even, staring out
the window at the tree, thinking
of how that thin pane of glass
made the tree seem so far away.
Plucking a leaf from
a low hanging branch,
Drucker considered
that it wasn't the fact
that the tree was real
that was so remarkable,
but rather how easy
it had been to touch.
All he had done was get up
from his desk, walk outside,
and there it was
waiting for him.
Drucker lowered
himself to the ground,
where he sat leaning
against the tree,
careful to shield himself
with its wide trunk
so that no one inside the
building could see him.
It felt right to be outside
in the fresh air with his back
facing the bank.
A lifetime, a life, could be
sucked away in that office,
and his would be if
he didn't walk away.
If he wasn't fired
after the board meeting,
Drucker decided, he
would have to quit.
But why stop there?
If you could leave
Atlanta Southern,
he might as well leave
Atlanta altogether.
He could go North,
perhaps to Boston.
He'd been 15 when
Lucy's mother had died.
She'd moved back to Boston
to be with her sisters,
and 15 was too old
for a governess,
his mother had
declared, and so Lucy
had been placed neither
in Drucker's home,
nor in his heart.
For the first time
in quite a while,
Drucker felt a rush
of excitement course
through his veins.
In Atlanta, everyone knew
him before they even met him.
Whether he worked at Atlanta
Southern National Bank or not,
he would be known
as his father's son.
If he were to go
to Boston though,
there he could be anybody.
He could be the son
of a banker as easily
as he could be the
son of a farmer,
if they had farmers in Boston.
He'd have to check.
Maybe he would say
that his father
had died on a whaling ship and
left Drucker and his mother
with nothing.
Or maybe he would say that
he was a descendant of one
of those men who had
poured tea into the harbor
or signed the Constitution.
Yes, Boston would be
the perfect place.
He even had the
accent down perfectly
after years of spending
so much time with Lucy.
As a child, he'd
taken special notice
of the way and words tripped
off her tongue a little faster,
the way she hit
consonants a little harder
than the native-born
Southern ladies he knew.
Often, during their
long afternoons
together, he would switch
into his Northern accent,
changing the pace and
style of his speech
as if he were speaking
another language.
At first, Lucy had laughed.
But then she became like the
teacher she had once been,
gently correcting him when
he lapsed for a moment.
We say "get," not
"git," she'd say.
Rhymes with "bet."
And Drucker would repeat
after her, quickly
picking up on the distinctly
Northern vernacular.
The happy yelps of children
chasing one another
down Peachtree Street
snapped Drucker back
to the present moment.
Two hours must have
passed, he thought,
as he pushed off the ground
and rose to his feet.
He walked back toward the bank,
which looked different somehow
now that he was taking it in
with the eyes of a man who knew
he would soon be leaving it.
As he paced slowly down the
hallway back to his office,
he felt the sturdy clap of
the hand on his shoulder.
Drucker turned to see his father
with Hank trailing behind him
like a faithful Labrador.
"There you are," said
the bank's president.
"I've been looking for you, but
you weren't in your office."
"I stepped outside,"
said Drucker.
"Oh?
asked the president, a bit
surprised, "and what were you
doing out there?" "I was
just doing some thinking,"
answered Drucker,
not untruthfully.
The president brightened.
"That's my boy," he beamed.
"My best business ideas always
congeal when I'm taking a walk.
So you've come up
with a plan, then?"
"Well, there are still
some details to attend to,"
said Drucker, thinking of
his recently hatched plan
to leave Atlanta. "Well, by all
means, attend to the details,"
roared the president
with excitement.
He took a step
closer to Drucker,
his nose twitching as he
examined his son's face.
"By God, you're close, Drucker.
I can sense it.
I can always smell a good
idea, and--" he turned his head
and sniffed the air.
"It sure does smell
like you've got
something juicy cooking."
Drucker smiled meekly.
"I do you think may
be on to something,"
he said-- again,
not untruthfully.
The president, smiling heartily,
patted Drucker on the back.
"You remind me of
myself, Drucker,"
he said happily,
eyeing Drucker's well
kept blond hair and manly jaw.
"Though more handsome than I
ever was, I must admit."
He cleared his throat and
averted his eyes from his son's
charming dimples. "At any
rate, if any one can get us out
of this, you can, Drucker."
Drucker tried to protest,
but the president was already
waddling proudly down the
hall, forgetting about Hank,
who hung back with Drucker.
"So what were you
really doing out there?"
asked Hank, nudging
Drucker in the ribs
as soon as the president
was out of earshot.
"Thinking," repeated
Drucker earnestly.
"About?"
Hank sneered.
"Trees," said Drucker,
"I was thinking
about what happens to them
when they die." "Fascinating,"
scoffed Hank.
"Not exactly the
stuff plans to save
a bank are made of though."
He raised his right eyebrow
high with skepticism.
"Come to any groundbreaking
conclusions?"
"Yes," said Drucker,
"they become desks.""
[APPLAUSE]
SEEMA VASHI: Thanks
for reading that.
LAUREN EPSHTEYN: Of
course, thank you.
SEEMA VASHI: I have a
couple extra question.
How many times have
you read the book?
LAUREN EPSHTEYN: OK,
so in the editing phase
I probably the whole
thing four or five times.
And since then,
probably three or so.
SEEMA VASHI: And do you have
off like a favorite chapter?
Was that one of your favorites?
LAUREN EPSHTEYN: That
was one of my favorites,
in part because we start to see
evidence of one trait that's
true to Drucker that makes
the rest of the book so fun,
and it's stated outright
in another chapter.
Drucker refuses to
lie at any point,
and that's part of what
makes it so fun to see
him change his identity over and
over again, because he does it
all without ever
telling a boldfaced lie,
at least on purpose, yes.
SEEMA VASHI: So now let's get
two Googlers up here who've
read the book,
and we can kind of
facilitate a nice discussion,
a little mini book club.
So that's Lindsay
Siano and Ariel Garber.
LAUREN EPSHTEYN: There you go.
Thank you, guys.
Come on up here.
SEEMA VASHI: So if you guys
want to quickly introduce
yourselves, maybe
the team you're
on, how much you love
Lauren's new book.
LINDSAY SIANO: How
much time do we have?
I'm Lindsay Siano.
I've worked with Lauren
since she started.
LAUREN EPSHTEYN:
A long time ago.
LINDSAY SIANO: Yeah, we both
started around the same time
a long time ago.
And now I'm an account
manager on the publishing
pod over in LCS.
So I've been working with
a lot of different book
publishers and
different imprints,
and I'm an avid reader.
And I was so excited
for Lauren that she
achieved this amazing goal.
And I was so excited to read it.
And I hope all of you read it
because it's a great story.
ARIEL GARBER: And
I'm Ariel Garber.
I've known Lauren for
about three years.
Lauren is a huge
inspiration for me.
I followed her to
business school.
I followed her on the team.
She's amazing.
And for me, this
book was so exciting
because you read the book,
and you see Lauren's ideas
flowing through it, and it's
such a great journey, so super
excited to be here.
LAUREN EPSHTEYN: Thank you.
SEEMA VASHI: Thanks to
both of you for joining.
And just to kind of
kick off a discussion,
you guys recently
finished the book.
And before we get
inside the book,
let's talk about the
cover for a second.
So for those of you can
see a book in front of you,
there's kind of like a circular
frame, and you see this man.
But you don't actually
see Drucker's face.
We're assuming that is Drucker.
So what did you
two think of that?
Did it bother you?
Did it make sense later
as to why that happened?
Let's start with Lindsay.
LINDSAY SIANO: Sure,
so it didn't bother me.
I'm pretty imaginative
when I read books.
I like to think
of the character.
And you gave some description,
but I also liked the sense
that you don't really
know what he looks like,
and he keeps
reinventing himself,
so I thought it was
like a nice touch
that you don't really
know what he looks like.
ARIEL GARBER: Yeah,
I agree, and you
see the character really evolve
throughout the whole book.
So you get the sense that he's
very much a different sort
of looking person, both
physically and also emotionally
who he is and what he
stands for, by the end.
So it's fun to kind of not
have all those details.
You can really reinvent
your perception of him
as the book evolves.
LAUREN EPSHTEYN: I
don't know even now
if I have a really clear
vision of his face.
I certainly know
those traits about him
that I mentioned that
were even in this chapter.
But that's just not part of
it for me is exactly what
his face looks like.
SEEMA VASHI: And it's not as
important either, I guess.
LAUREN EPSHTEYN: Yeah, I
think the reinvention aspect
and that keeps changing
his identity is much more
integral to the story.
SEEMA VASHI: Absolutely,
so another big-- oh,
there's a question.
Should we take some now?
AUDIENCE: I'm sorry.
Somebody pinged me that
they're on the hangout.
LAUREN EPSHTEYN:
There is no hangout.
AUDIENCE: They're not on there?
LAUREN EPSHTEYN:
There is no hang out.
Sorry, that may have
accidentally been a--
SEEMA VASHI: We're
recording it though.
LAUREN EPSHTEYN:
Authors at Google
does not allow VC
hangout or live stream,
so we are pushing it to the
YouTube channel instead.
AUDIENCE: Got it, thanks.
LINDSAY SIANO: Actually,
the one thing I would say
is it's interesting when
you read the book, the women
characters, the
female characters,
are described a lot, and the
male characters aren't as much.
LAUREN EPSHTEYN:
Oh, that's true.
No, that's a good point.
That's actually--
the female characters
was a pretty big part
of this book for me.
To me, things come in threes.
He has three stops,
but for his place
that he leaves and the
place that he ends up.
And in each of these stops there
is a different type of woman.
Although, technically,
that would make it four,
because there's two
in the first stop.
But I didn't want them to be
quote unquote, "stereotypes,"
but I wanted them
to be representative
of certain types of women.
Without giving
anything too much away,
the type of woman
who you just see
as a friend, the type of
woman who you really just have
a physical relationship
with, the type of woman who's
all those things, the type of
woman who maybe doesn't even
seem like a woman,
who is practically
not a woman in some
ways, you'll have
to read on to figure out some of
her traits and characteristics.
But, yeah, that was
definitely-- and I
agree that there was
in some ways a lot
more description of
the other characters'
physical description
than of Drucker.
SEEMA VASHI: So another big
part of "The Northern Gentlemen"
that's in the title,
the sense of geography.
There's this sense that you
know where it potentially
is coming from or going.
But the description of Drucker
being this Northern gentleman--
he's from actually the South.
There's tension between
the East and West.
He's traveling.
He's supposed to be
kind of traveling west,
but he means to go north.
So what role did
geography play for you
two as readers as you were
reading through the book?
LINDSAY SIANO: I thought
it was interesting.
I think you really
captured a sense of this--
he goes to these small
towns, where a lot of people
have never left,
and he's like kind
of this-- they're all a
little suspicious of him
because he's a traveller.
And I thought that
that was really great,
because it's true.
It's like, now we all
travel all the time.
We don't think about it.
But I really did feel
like the train was almost
like a character
in the book, and I
don't want to say
his accomplice,
because he wasn't going
the right direction.
But it was interesting to me.
I don't know if I'm
answering your question.
I think it was funny he clung
to the Northern gentleman,
even though he went
other places and never--
he never changed that.
ARIEL GARBER: It's funny--
since it's in the 1890s,
you kind of forget how travel
was big deal back then,
and for him, he's
really this innovator.
So as he goes to these
different cities,
it's the first time
anyone's met someone
who's kind of traveled
the landscape like he has,
and he has this
wealth of knowledge
that he carries to every city.
Which makes it really
exciting as a reader,
because we're learning about
these cities for the first time
in the context of 1890.
But he carries a
piece of these cities
throughout the whole journey.
So you really get
kind of a sense
of what the 1890s felt like
from an American West expansion
perspective.
LAUREN EPSHTEYN: I love
those two interpretations.
I would just add to it that
to me this westward moving
was such a big part
of American history.
And I originally, in the first
weeks of having this idea,
I wanted his arrival in
the West, so to speak,
to coincide with the
closing of the frontier,
when they made this announcement
that there was no more America
to discover.
They had made it as
far west as possible.
So I thought that
that was interesting.
And there are a few parts
sort of tongue-in-cheek
at points where the phrase
"The Northern Gentleman"
comes up over and over again.
At one point, someone
actually says to him,
you really are a true Northern
gentleman, and he's not.
He's not a Northerner, and
sometimes he's not a gentleman.
So the fact that this
person who knew him so well
would make that
statement, I thought,
was pretty indicative of-- yes?
AUDIENCE: I have a question.
They're both talking about
learning about these cities
in the 1890s.
How did you learn about cities?
Every time I watch a movie or
read something of a period,
I'm like, how do
these people know?
LAUREN EPSHTEYN: Yes, OK, so
I give all thanks to Google
the search engine for making
so many details available.
I would Google things-- this
isn't so much about the city--
but as small as what did
coffee smell like in 1890?
And get multiple blog hits
answering that question.
Turns out it was
nutty, and it was
something called Arbuckles
was the famous coffee in Texas
in the 1890s.
So, yeah, there was
a lot of googling
that went on all the time.
But in the first stop--
so Atlanta was real,
and there were some real details
about Atlanta's Union Station
that were easily discoverable.
I read a couple of
books, especially
about a real
character from Texas
who makes it into the book.
Actually, I read maybe
three or four books
about different characters
that played into it.
But a lot of, yeah, just
like real time googling
that I don't know how
historical fiction could've
been written 15, 20
years ago before Google.
You would have had to hole
up in the Library of Congress
with your research
team and fact checkers.
But it's different.
AUDIENCE: That's
probably what happened.
LAUREN EPSHTEYN: Right.
SEEMA VASHI: Or it
just wasn't accurate.
LAUREN EPSHTEYN: Right.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So this
is very timely,
because my eight-year-old son
is studying the expedition
of Lewis and Clark.
LAUREN EPSHTEYN: Ah, yes.
We'll have to get him the
censored version of "A Northern
Gentleman."
AUDIENCE: I know.
LAUREN EPSHTEYN:
Select scenes cut out.
AUDIENCE: But
actually my question
has nothing to do with that.
My question is more about you
from a personal perspective.
I'm very interested in, as a
mom, the power of possibility
and teaching my kids that
they can do anything.
So I'm curious to
know, at 10 years old,
knowing that you wanted
to write a "New York
Times" bestseller,
how much influence was
that from your parents.
LAUREN EPSHTEYN:
Oh, I love that,
and they're going
to love this when
they watch it on YouTube once
I tell them what YouTube is.
My mom was huge in that.
She used to type out
my stories for me
when I was 10 years old,
before I could type.
Yeah, I have very
distinct memories
of sitting next to a computer
with her before I could type,
and dictating out loud, and
she would type them out.
So that was big.
And then there's a callout
in the acknowledgements
at the end where I call
out to both my parents.
In the end, I really don't
want to ruin anything
for anyone who hasn't read
it, but there's this concept
that his father has
collected things for him
in case he ever misses home.
And my dad did that
similarly for me.
I have not been
living in Minneapolis
since I was 18
years old, and I've
gotten a lot of mailings,
like physical envelopes
in the mail with pictures
and things from home.
So there's a lot of
support in that way, too.
AUDIENCE: That's great.
LAUREN EPSHTEYN:
Thanks for asking that.
SEEMA VASHI: So moving from the
geography, let's move to names.
So we all know just
from this discussion
that Drucker is the main
character of the book.
Were there any names
as you were reading
that you found particularly
noteworthy-- Drucker,
in particular?
We can maybe start there.
Any things that come to mind?
ARIEL GARBER: So you've really
got a sense that every name was
specific to the city.
He's traveling
westward, and it felt
like it was part of the fabric
of the community, these names,
which was, again,
really fun to listen to.
But for me, I felt
like I was maybe
supposed to know who
these people were,
so I was constantly googling,
like, is this a real person?
And half the time they were,
and half the time they weren't.
So for me, it was
really kind of weaving
in what was actually
true and not, which was
a fun part of reading the book.
LAUREN EPSHTEYN: On
that note, I will just
say there's one name that
sometimes people say, OK,
an overweight guy named Hogg.
Come on, that's a
little on the nose.
Truer than fiction, you can't
create some of these things.
A real governor from the state
of Texas was a very overweight
man, whose name is
Jim Hogg-- H-O-G-G.
And that's one of the people
who I read a book about.
So that was not a made-up name.
Three characters who
are real from the book--
Jim Hogg, who became
governor of Texas in 1890
and was attorney
general before that.
And technically his
campaign manager
Horace, who goes
by first name only,
so I guess that makes it four.
Jay Gould, who's a pretty
nefarious character
from American business
history, and a guy
named William A. Clark, who I
had read a book about, somewhat
randomly, who was a senator from
Montana who owned big copper
mines, and was a
long-time senator-- I
mentioned that-- and
had a daughter who
lived to 105 in New York.
And that was the one the book
was about-- his daughter.
Anyway, names, any names that--
LINDSAY SIANO: Well,
I thought Drucker
was such a Southern name,
because it felt like sometimes
in the South they named their
children after the mother's
maiden name as the first name.
So I was thinking
that really fit.
And just like Ariel was saying,
it really felt like every place
that he went to, there were
sort of distinctive names.
So I thought it
was really clever.
LAUREN EPSHTEYN:
Yeah, thank you.
I like that.
One note about
Drucker May itself,
if you are curious
about the name,
Drucker I got the idea
for-- Peter Drucker
is this sort of well known
celebrated father of management
organization, for anyone
who's in business classes.
And I like the name for
exactly the reason you said.
It sounded like a
Southern name that
could have been passed down.
And May, the month of
May, spring, optimism,
anything "may" do anything
he sets his mind to,
that was sort of
the inspirations.
SEEMA VASHI: I love it.
I'm from Texas, so
I know who Hogg is.
LAUREN EPSHTEYN: Oh, really?
Oh, my, OK.
SEEMA VASHI: Yeah, very
infamously overweight,
and we made fun of
that his last name was
Hogg when we were learning about
Texas history in seventh grade.
So I love that he
made it into the book.
That's great.
I think one last
question for you guys.
Did you root for Drucker?
Was he this rooted
for protagonist
that you kind of kept
throughout the book,
or did that change at all?
LAUREN EPSHTEYN:
Did he save the cat?
SEEMA VASHI: Yeah,
did he save the cat?
LINDSAY SIANO: I definitely
was rooting for him.
I think, at first,
I was curious as
to sort of how he would--
someone who'd lived in one
place their whole
life, how is he
going to grasp moving to a
new place or finding a job
or whatever he wanted to do?
I think I was rooting for
him more when things didn't
go the way he had planned,
because I was sort of like,
oh, you can figure it out.
You can do it.
So I don't know how
he saved the cat,
but he totally did
it for me, yeah.
ARIEL GARBER: Yeah, I mean,
I think when you first
start the book, it's
all about self discovery
and finding yourself, and
you want him, as a reader,
to find himself
and find himself.
There are things in the
book you watch him do,
and you want to stop
him from doing it.
You get a little angry
that he's doing it
because you know he has
a better moral character.
So there are instances
that are frustrating,
but I think net-net
you really feel
like you want him to ultimately
find what he's looking for.
Pros and cons of
knowing the author, when
you get to things, it's like,
why did you make him do that?
LINDSAY SIANO: I think also
what was realistic about it.
We all make huge mistakes.
Sometimes we can come back
from them, sometimes we can't.
So I thought that that
was great because it
wasn't like a seamless
kind of journey.
SEEMA VASHI: Yeah, like overly
romantic or anything like that.
LINDSAY SIANO: No, it was good.
SEEMA VASHI: And
why did you choose
to make Drucker a male
protagonist in this story?
LAUREN EPSHTEYN:
Totally fair question.
I didn't see a way
that a female character
could have gone on this
particular journey in 1890.
There would have been more
requirements about having
a chaperone, or questions
about why a single woman was
showing up new in town.
So I always envisioned
Drucker as a male character.
But that's-- I think I
mentioned this earlier with
the exploration of women--
this is definitely a book that
explores gender
in different ways.
So that absolutely was on my
mind just in terms of a theme.
SEEMA VASHI: No, that's great,
especially at that time period.
There's probably a lot.
Did you research that, too?
LAUREN EPSHTEYN: Yeah, I read
a lot of historical fiction
that took place in
that time period.
And then that paired
with frequent googling
of different specific
questions was really useful.
There are also things that I
found through Google searches,
like train travel maps from
1890s and the progress.
I just got a question last
week, could someone actually
have made that journey?
Did the train routes exist?
And I'm happy to share the link.
I have a train route from 1890
that shows pretty much yes.
So the second stop he makes in
Arkansas is a fictional town.
So let's assume it's like in
the perfect place, then yes.
And then he could have
gone on to Austin.
And then for anyone
who's wondering,
was there a direct
train route from Texas
to where he goes to next?
I don't want to give
it away too much.
Perhaps not
directly, but yet, we
don't say that he gets
off the train specifically
where he does.
So there's a little bit of
room for making up how he
got from one place to another.
SEEMA VASHI: Love it.
That's awesome.
I'm sure in Kindle it's
fun, too, to actually
look these things up.
LAUREN EPSHTEYN: Yes, the
Kindle version's re-release
will be much more
fun than it is now.
Actually, it's one of my
things I wanted to mention,
if the question about
publishing comes up,
is there's always going to be
quirks and kinks to work out,
but hopefully, the Kindle
version will be back and better
than after in about two weeks.
SEEMA VASHI: So those
were the questions
I had for the discussion.
And I wanted to pause here,
and we can definitely still
take Q&A with everyone up here.
Does anyone have any
questions in mind?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Thank you so
much for [INAUDIBLE].
It's incredible.
LAUREN EPSHTEYN: Thanks, well,
I was in the building today
anyway.
AUDIENCE: But you just mentioned
the publishing process.
LAUREN EPSHTEYN: Yes.
AUDIENCE: It is something
that I am curious about.
What was that process like for
you for this particular book?
LAUREN EPSHTEYN: Yes, what was
the publishing process like?
All right, so there's
a couple of things
I can say about the
publishing process.
I've learned a lot about it
through going through it,
but also asking everyone
I know, what do you know
about the publishing process?
And so if anyone is interested
in publishing their own book,
I can tell you the typical
traditional publishing
route, as it used
to be especially,
and can still be today, is
it starts with query letters
to agents.
You write maybe 30 to 40
to 50 and get rejected
that amount of times minus one.
And then that agent says
that they will represent you,
and then they query all the
publishing houses, and they get
rejected all but one time.
And those are the two
parties that you then
need to split all of the
royalties with later on.
Those parties can change
anything about your book
that they want.
They can change the title.
They can create the cover.
They can tell you
to cut out parts.
Actually, I know
Dave can probably
speak to this in some ways.
I don't want to
sound too negative.
But from what I've
understood, they
can tell you what to change
about your book, right?
Dave's nodding quietly,
for the record.
What's that?
AUDIENCE: It depends
on your contract.
LAUREN EPSHTEYN: It
depends on the contract.
AUDIENCE: It depends on how
hard you fight about it.
LAUREN EPSHTEYN:
Exactly, exactly.
I chose a different
route because I
wanted complete creative control
over the title, the cover,
and this particular story.
In the future, I may be
totally willing to do
a different option.
But for this particular story,
it had been in the works
for so long.
I was impatient to hold it.
I self published through
my own publishing company,
which any of you can do.
It takes about $100 to set up
your own publishing company.
And then I published
this one through an arm
called CreateSpace,
an arm of Amazon.
In the past, I had published a
nonfiction book through Barnes
and Noble's equivalent
self publishing arm
called iUniverse.
And that process allows the
author complete control over
the creative decisions,
like cover, title, and text,
but also over the
marketing decisions,
which sometimes happens
with real publishers,
sometimes doesn't.
But that means that all the
marketing decisions from here
on out are going to be my
own and those of the people
who I choose to bring in on it.
Yes, Annette?
AUDIENCE: So how much time
is the publicity portion
and the publishing portion?
I'm just thinking [INAUDIBLE]
I can write a book,
and then it's like this whole
business on the other side
that--
LAUREN EPSHTEYN:
Yes, I just read
in a book about how to market
your book, which I just bought,
that when you finish the
book and it's published,
you're 50% of the way through.
Then you have a whole other half
of the process to market it.
I have a Google
Doc going with all
of the different ideas
people have given me,
and there's quite a few.
It could take a long time
to do it all by myself.
But you can also hire people,
outsource the work a little.
But some of the
things that people
told me are most important
are social media,
people have told me, are
incredibly important.
My first move in this
friends and family phase
was to just write a personal
email to just about everyone
I knew.
Knocked off about 100
with this Google invite.
But other than that, I wrote 350
personal emails asking people
hey, what's going on with you?
I just wrote a book.
SEEMA VASHI: Yes, Henry?
AUDIENCE: So from finishing
a first draft, what
was the timeline from there?
How many drafts?
How long did it
take to get to this?
LAUREN EPSHTEYN: Interesting.
OK, so my process of
writing, personally,
is I edit constantly and
frequently as I'm writing.
So there was never
a time where I just
had one full draft unedited.
I had gone back and
really done so much of it
as I was going
chapter by chapter.
But I finished a first
draft, so to speak,
in February of this year.
And then I sent it off
to a professional editor,
who I note in the
acknowledgements.
I thought I had it
in pretty good shape.
I'd read through it a few times.
She caught over 4,000
little typos or changes
that she wanted make.
She missed about seven,
but that's another story.
And that took about-- she sent
those back to me mid-June.
I did another full read through
and made a couple more changes,
and then sent it off
to the publisher,
the final publication,
in the beginning of July.
So it really wasn't that long.
But then again, I had
spent years, at least
the last two,
solidly both writing,
but really editing as I went.
Yeah, good question.
SEEMA VASHI: When did you know
it was time to stop editing?
LAUREN EPSHTEYN: Oh,
that's a good question.
The story felt finished to me
in terms of creating the plot.
And then I liked
the way it read,
and it felt like the story
I had set out to create.
And that's probably
the most rewarding part
of this whole project is
what I can hold in my hand
now or read on Kindle now is
the story that I had envisioned,
with far fewer details
in the beginning,
but that I had originally
set out to write.
SEEMA VASHI: That's great.
LAUREN EPSHTEYN: Did you
have a question, [INAUDIBLE]?
AUDIENCE: Yes, first of all,
I'm totally floored by the fact
that you did this.
And then reading made
me even more excited.
So thanks for sharing.
I was wondering, in terms of
your tone and your writing
style, you made it sound
like it was so easy.
It just flowed right out of you.
I was wondering, did you kind
of perfect your writing style
as you were wrapping
up the book,
or was it like that
from the very beginning?
If you write your
stories, will it
sort of have this similar feel?
LAUREN EPSHTEYN: I
love that question.
My writing developed
so much over the years.
I mentioned it was just under
seven years from the time
when it was published
from the time when I first
started writing.
And it was funny going back
and rereading the things
I had written years ago.
My writing style
had changed a lot.
And when I'm talking
about editing,
most of what I was doing was
changing sentences, where never
use 10 words, when 5 will do.
And when I started
writing, younger writer,
relatively close to being
just out of college,
I was much more florid
with the language
and used way too many words.
And so I cut down a lot.
That was the biggest
part of the editing
and the change in
my perspective.
And I had read a lot more books
that influenced my writing
style by that point.
LINDSAY SIANO: The
writing is so good.
LAUREN EPSHTEYN: Thank you.
LINDSAY SIANO: Yeah,
that was actually
one thing I was so impressed
by was just the way
that Lauren writes.
LAUREN EPSHTEYN: Thank you.
I will say I am writing a second
completely unrelated book.
Drucker is not in it.
It's not historical
in the same way.
It takes place in the second
half of the 20th century.
I think the
writing-- personally,
I think the writing style's
very different in there.
I don't know why.
This writing style felt very
authentic to this story,
and not as much to
a different one.
Dave?
AUDIENCE: How did
you relentlessly
carve out the time for
the past seven years?
Jobs are changing.
Personal situations
are changing.
Did you create this objective
requirement for yourself;
you have to get a certain amount
done per week and per month?
LAUREN EPSHTEYN:
I really didn't.
At times, I had the challenge,
which you and I have talked
about, with 100 words a day.
At times, I stuck to that.
And at other times.
I truly didn't.
And times I would have a weekend
trip with a big chunk of time
during travel, I could
bang out a few hours.
And then I wouldn't have
time again for several weeks.
It was sporadic.
But I would say
there was two years,
from spring 2013 to
spring 2015, when,
even if it wasn't my first
priority-- work was a priority.
Family was a priority.
Those two things came first.
But after that, I made
general timelines for myself
that I would want
to finish a given
section of the five sections
in a certain amount of months.
And then it was up
to me to figure out
how in that time period I was
going to allocate the time.
Yeah, [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: Congratulations.
LAUREN EPSHTEYN: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: And I'm going
to bring up the pen name.
Looking at the graphic and
the image of the cover,
I perceive a parallel between
his anonymous anonymity
and your pen name.
Is that intentional?
LAUREN EPSHTEYN:
I love that idea.
It really wasn't, but
that's a great idea.
I mean.
I [INAUDIBLE] what
you're saying.
SEEMA VASHI: You can use
that in a future interview.
AUDIENCE: Did you identify
with his changing identities?
I just feel like,
I don't know, maybe
even with this liberty with
the pen name with writing?
LAUREN EPSHTEYN: I
absolutely love that.
You know what I'll
say in response
to that is that
wasn't, at least,
in the forefront of
my mind at the time.
This concept of is it ever
too late to change your life?
That was on the
forefront of my mind.
And if you're unhappy
with your job,
or you're unhappy
with your, let's
say, marriage or
way you're living,
I bet there are people
in this room who
are on their second or
third Google office.
Like, it's never too
late to just start again.
And that concept was
definitely something
that I thought about a lot as he
goes from city to city changing
his identity.
The pen name, I like that.
I might say that in
the future. [INAUDIBLE]
But it really was a mixture of
the unisex All-American, paired
with the Google identity
versus-- so in a way, I guess,
having my work identity separate
from my writing identity.
AUDIENCE: Do you think you
wrote things under this name
that you wouldn't
feel comfortable with?
LAUREN EPSHTEYN:
No, I really don't.
I really don't.
There are a couple sex scenes
in here, just enough to get you
reading.
But no, nothing that-- and,
as you saw on the posters,
have been saying Lauren Epshteyn
using pen name Lane Everett.
AUDIENCE: Who's going
to direct the movie?
LAUREN EPSHTEYN: I've
been asked who I think
would make good characters.
I don't know.
I think we might have even
been talking this that I
don't-- while I don't have an
exact picture of who would be
Drucker, I just
love Leo DiCaprio.
SEEMA VASHI: He also does a
ton of historical fiction.
LINDSAY SIANO: Ryan Gosling.
SEEMA VASHI: Is he
particularly good looking?
Do you want him to
be good looking?
LAUREN EPSHTEYN: Yes,
he's good looking.
SEEMA VASHI: Charming?
LAUREN EPSHTEYN: Yep,
all these things, so.
Kristen?
AUDIENCE: So Google Media
Sales is definitely a calling.
LAUREN EPSHTEYN: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Do you see yourself--
LAUREN EPSHTEYN:
It's the Lord's work.
[?
AUDIENCE: --having
the passion point
to maybe one day becoming
a full time writer?
LAUREN EPSHTEYN:
It's been a long time
since I wanted to be a
full time writer, probably
around the time I wrote
that questionnaire when
I was 10 years old.
I don't know.
That's not the goal.
I'll just leave it at that.
As I just mentioned, I am
working on the second book
because I found it to
be such a fun hobby.
But I also really enjoy
having it as a hobby
and not as the way that
the bills are paid.
Because after three
months of sales,
the bills are not paid
off with this book.
Yes, Abbie?
AUDIENCE: Did you write
this chronologically?
LAUREN EPSHTEYN: Yes, I did.
I did.
Because I had written section
one-- there's five sections.
I wrote section one and then
put it down for four years.
That was pretty
much a clean break.
So yes, I wrote it
all chronologically.
But section one
was heavily edited,
and I would even say that
the plot wasn't changed,
but the writing style
was very much changed,
and I went back and
fixed that years later.
LINDSAY SIANO: Can I
ask a followup question?
Did you know what
you wanted the ending
to be before you got to the end?
LAUREN EPSHTEYN:
That's interesting.
The ending was one
of the few things
that I wasn't as clear on,
but when this idea came to me,
it came to me pretty much
all at once back in 2008,
when I started it-- this concept
of five sections, the places
that each one would be.
And then generally the
concept, without telling you
how it ends, that it would
end in a fairly abrupt way
in the place where it does and
with the ultimate resolution
it has.
So, no, I had an idea that
that was going to happen,
but exactly how it
all came together,
I didn't know originally.
Yes, Leah?
AUDIENCE: Hey, Lauren, I'm
so glad I could be here.
So I just had a quick
question about the book.
So the book takes
place in the 1890s.
How did you think the readers
today would relate to it?
LAUREN EPSHTEYN:
Yes, you're so right.
Yes, the book takes
place in the 1890s,
and it's historical fiction.
But I think this
more than anything--
that Drucker is positioned
to ask a question-- somewhat
uniquely positioned
for his generation
to ask the question that
we're all asking ourselves,
which is, what should
I do with my life,
and am I spending my
life the right way?
And because Drucker had
the money and the position
he could ask himself that.
He had the luxury of
asking himself that.
But I do think that the question
at the heart of this book
is what so many of us
today in our generation
what we spend so
much time asking.
SEEMA VASHI: He's
the first Millennial?
LAUREN EPSHTEYN: Yeah, he's
the first Millennial, exactly.
Well, thank you all so much
for coming [INAUDIBLE].
[APPLAUSE]